today's video is all about wands in Enel
crossing new horizons and everything you
need to know about them wizard what do
they do how can you get them and how
many kinds are there let's go ahead and
jump into it right now people of the
internet retro raconteur here and
welcome back to another animal crossing
new horizons video one of my favourite
items in the game has to be the wand or
wands plural as there are quite a few of
them here's a quick look at all the
different types of ones you can get in
Animal Crossing new horizons and here in
a bit we're gonna go through each wand
and I'll show you exactly how they're
obtained if you don't have a one yet and
you're unsure what they do it's pretty
straightforward wands are simply a tool
for quickly changing outfits anytime
anywhere if you're new to the game you
may have found out about once through a
DIY recipe or perhaps you saw someone
else using one I actually found out by
getting multiple DIY recipes before I
ever knew their actual function in the
game
wands can be equipped like any other
tools such as a shovel or fishing rod
the purpose of the wand though is to
quickly alter your appearance without
having to access a wardrobe item or
going into your inventory to swap out
different pieces of your outfit so even
though there are different types of
wands in the game they all have the same
purpose so how do you go about obtaining
these wands there are two steps you'll
need to complete to make your own one
and you're about to see why it's been so
hard for me to get those recipes first
you'll have to get the correct recipe
second you'll need to find the
appropriate crafting items now most of
the recipes are obtained from celeste so
make sure you talk to her anytime you
see her visiting and she'll always have
a recipe for you unfortunately the
recipes from celeste won't always be
wand recipes now there are also certain
wands tied to special events in the game
there's the bug wand and fish wand which
are both obtained as rewards from their
respective events ie the bug off and
fishing tournament the bunny day wand
was obtained after completing the entire
bunny day series of furniture for zipper
cherry blossom wand is from the cherry
blossom festival you'll have a chance at
the ice wand DIY recipe for making
perfect snow boys during winter time the
mushroom wand can be obtained tearing
you guessed it mushrooming season
there's also the wedding wand which is a
recipe you can get from Syrus after
completing seven days of photo shoots
during wedding season and finally
there's the shell wand which you
obtain from your regular DIY recipe
sources now all the other Wan recipes I
haven't mentioned so far are obtained
from Celeste so here we go the cosmos
golden hyacinth iron lily pansy rose
star tree branch tulip wand and the wind
flower are all wand recipes you'll need
to get from Celeste or trading with a
friend of course so if you have your
sights set on a particular one now you
know how to get the recipe but that's
only half the battle you see one recipes
do require star fragments which is
somewhat of a rare item in the game the
only way to get them is by wishing on a
star during meteor showers the star
fragments will then wash on your Shore
throughout the next day
make sure you wish on as many shooting
stars as you can and also check the
beach a couple of times over the course
of the next day as the star fragments
will continue to appear if you're having
a hard time catching a meteor shower
then you may want to check out media
nook a free online tool that will show
you the exact day and time you need to
be on the lookout for shooting stars I
made a whole separate video on media
nuke as there is quite a bit of setup
involved and I'll be sure to include a
link to that down in the description
below ok so you got your recipe you
crafted your wand now how do you
actually use the thing before you can
use the wand you'll want to create a few
different outfit combinations you can
make up to eight and you'll need to do
so from any wardrobe style item even
items like coolers and refrigerators
will work strange I know it's pretty
straightforward to set them up from
there but unfortunately there are a few
strange limitations first if you have
any items you'd like to use across
multiple outfits say a specific pair of
socks a hat you love or your beard yes
for some reason beers or cosmetic items
in this game I don't get it it makes me
mad I I have a beard but if that's the
case then you'll only be able to use
that item on one outfit if you want to
use it in more than one unfortunately
you'll need to buy multiple versions of
the item yeah you got it that means I
have to buy multiple beards you also
can't set your wet suit as a wand outfit
but you can easily get around this by
starting off wearing your wet suit and
then using your wand to change into your
preloaded outfits any time you want to
switch back to the wet suit you simply
remove your current outfit with your
wand
another small downside is you won't be
able to enter the changing room at the a
sister shop while wearing either a star
outfit or your wet suit even with those
limitations though wands are a fantastic
fun addition to the game especially if
you have multiple outfits you like to
wear and come on this is animal crossing
who doesn't have multiple outfits they
want to wear I'm hopeful the down the
line will see a Nintendo iron out some
of those minor issues to make them even
better you should now be seeing two
videos popping up on the right side of
your screen one is all about setting up
the media Nook site so you can predict
your weather and meteor showers the
other is about that little trick I
mentioned regarding your wand and
wetsuit that's gonna be it for this
video I'll talk to you guys again soon